[music]
So hey everyone, thank you so much for
being here. So I'm Benedict from Alonic.
Uh and what I'm going to talk about is
exactly what was mentioned before,
manufacturing, the manufacturing layer
behind robotics and the way to make that
foundation happen for the next
generation and what we're building at
Alonic. A little bit of a background. I
spent the last just about eight eight
years from beyond my studies uh in
robotics in various fields of robotics.
So both advanced robotics for humanoids
both prosthetics so the ways and and the
applications that goes go the closest to
humans and and the various fields that
are enabling that and we started all
based on the notion that we discovered
as everyone knows during that process is
that robotics hardware is very
difficult. Big surprise there. There is
a huge amount of capital that needs to
flow into it in the beginning. Vast
supply chains and huge assembly
overheads that you need to overcome and
the entire process is slow and it takes
time to iterate. It takes money to
iterate. So the problem is that as you
start adding more complexity and more
function. This problem doesn't go away.
It becomes worse as you add more layers
of the technology and be and make your
hardware even more difficult to
compound. So this is one of the primary
reasons why there are still many many uh
jobs and many uh tasks in factories and
warehouses that are still left to
automate because simply the ROI is not
there yet. The integration, the
application, the learning and everything
included is still too high for many of
these use cases provided that there is
workforce to replace it. But this is
also a reason why when it comes to
having a new idea like we did when we
wanted to start a company with being a
research group simply having the ability
to spin it out and and do that
investment forward for building the
hardware and dealing with all the supply
chain setup needs and the
disproportionate MOQs etc is a main
reason why this hardware is still while
it is becoming more advanced it is still
kept back and it's still really
difficult to overcome these hurdles and
the big challenge is that as consumer
robotics and humanoid robotics on such a
scale scale are getting forward. This is
simply no longer going to stand because
we will have like think simply think
about the numbers. If you have 10
million humanoids per year that means 20
million hands per year and that means
that if you have your fixtures,
connections, joints etc. That means
billions and billions of extremely
complex mechanical components that you
have to somehow manufacture that you
have to somehow scale that you have to
somehow make reliable each and every
time. And so
yes, and so perfect example for this, I
think one of my favorite products out
there is the Sharpa hand, which is just
a marvel of engineering. Look at this
clockwork of function. And I think it's
per a perfect example of how beautiful
and how complex human motion is and and
and the versatility of what we want to
realize how the complexity of that is
and what is imagine the amount of work
that had to go into designing and
building and scaling something. the
number of components, the supply chains
behind the value chain behind this
entire thing and the fact that the real
life the the Mercury reality which you
you will eventually deploy such things
into how extremely difficult it is to
ensure that such things don't break. We
only have a very limited volume here. So
making sure that that stays on the top
of its game each and every component the
assembly line the repair lines that is
quite a difficult challenge right. So
the main problem is that the hands
always break because they are small
because you don't have this reliability.
It's very difficult to create this
reliability. You have massive assemblies
and extremely tedious processes behind
this. So you have all of these hundreds
of components and okay there are simple
cases but still a hand is insanely
complex. You have it and you have to
somehow assemble it. It's insanely
difficult to automate all of these task.
Like yeah, bolting is one thing, but if
you have a tendon driven hand, maybe
threat doing a knot, it's it's it's just
something that is so complex and so
difficult to put on a line, especially
if you have this level of complexity. So
this is one side of the things and at
the second there is this endless debate
of course of of general purpose robotics
like the whole humanoid race and the
task specific robotics like you know
each has different targets but the point
is that what is the leading argument for
general purpose and why do we even care
about humanoids right everyone probably
knows the answer sitting here is that we
build this world for the human form
factor so what we can do probably
something with a similar form factor can
also do there is the data to train it
there is already the environment set up
for it. But there is also another reason
which is kind of the reality check one
the economical one is that if you have a
single general purpose product you can
scale it. It's possible to just expand
production and to bring that single
solution to every single use case.
Basically, even though you have this
level of complexity, if you have a huge
supply chain and are able to build all
that inertia, that means that you can
actually get there. And this is I think
the most interesting problem of all in
this sense because the real challenge is
that could we somehow find a way to let
the environment decide? I think there is
a lot of realization right now in the
industry is how many problems humanoids
can solve. But it's it doesn't mean that
there is no need for task specific
robots. It doesn't mean that there is
not a context where both versatility and
both both precision could matter. It
doesn't mean that this is not a shared
space for all of them. But the problem
is that if you have anything task
specific or if you want to shift between
if you want flexibility in hardware
flexibility in hardware right so what am
I even talking about how can you even
reach that how is it possible to do that
so the question is that the first how do
the right bodies look like for each
environment when it comes to human
interaction how do they feel like it's a
very understated phenomenon of this
integration part
and how can we scale hardware how can we
scale any hardware ware how can we make
sure that it's not only one type and one
track of hardware that we can actually
scale and actually get there. How can we
make sure that this is not the only
scenario that happens but we can somehow
think differently about how to unlock
this scaling property in hardware and
this manufacturing property in hardware
and if we encounter a new problem which
maybe doesn't have the solutions may
maybe one or our one shoe doesn't really
fit all what can we do about it and so
this amounts to needing bodies that are
[snorts] first robust so meaning that
they actually can survive in the real
world and don't really break all the
time they are compliant which means that
they can actually work in these
unstructured environments safely. That's
that being the key word among us
indexers. So that means that they can
actually do the job and at the same time
on the other side of the things they
should be easy to design meaning that if
I come up with something new it
shouldn't break the bank to actually
bring it to market. It shouldn't cost me
an infinite amount of time to actually
get there and design it and prototype
it. And that's true in terms of
production that comes right at the next
step. We need to be able to iterate
faster. We need to be able to move from
prototype to prototype to production. We
need to be able to somehow bridge all
this gap. We have numerous technologies
out there which help us make it faster.
But still it's it's still a huge swath
of things and and [snorts] scale. We
need to be able to scale it in a way in
order for this to become reality where
the vast inertia of the supply chain is
actually bypassed where you don't need
to build up this entire thing which then
if you want to modify something causes a
cascade of of compounding effects but
it's something that you can actually
maybe completely go around and simp
circumvent do something about it. So it
seems like an impossible task in a sense
right. So this is the way to scale
hardware that is one of the main
problems.
So the question is [snorts] which
interests us at Alonic is that
[clears throat]
how could we simplify all of this the
production part the scaling part and
everything without doing what usually
needs to be done taking away complexity
from the hardware simplifying function
essentially since we have live in in the
advent of complex robotics we don't want
to simplify function that's the whole
point and so this notion and our
interest towards like this human safe
robotics is what brought us towards
textile technologies interestingly
enough because if If you think a little
bit around it, it's a really out of the
box concept, but we have the durability
there. It's absolutely we we have the
strength there. These are made for
extremely demanding applications. We
have softness and we have flexibility
and it's kind of a massive industry that
is right now on all of you basically. So
we have this proven scalability
and even within that
good ropes which if we really think
about it are the exact embedded demand
of robotics needs like the most
demanding applications really and the
heaviest loads that we need to bear the
flexible loadbearing structures could
they perhaps hold the answer. So the
interesting point in ropes is that if
you look at the connective tissue on our
body the collagen fibers actually on on
on a micro level even their helixes have
striking similarities to how these ropes
are made the properties which we can
reach in terms of load bearing per
cross-section are very very similar with
the proper technical materials could
even be exceeded
and it's a centuries old technology I
don't know if it's usually a trick
question but if anyone has previous
experience with how ropes are made, how
your shoelac is made. It's a very
surprisingly complex piece of technology
for a very very simple product. This
being uh key identificators. Basically
what happens is that gear these gears
are rotating. They're carrying bobbins
that are interlacing in a specific
pattern and then there comes your rope.
And the point is that we are actually
using them in robotics. There are a lot
of tendon driven robotics out there and
and yeah it's sure as every technology
it has its pros and cons but they work.
We've been using them for robotics.
We've been using them for highly
demanding applications like
mountaineering, sailing. It's it's a
huge industry and there's a lot of
potential. But the problem is that it's
still just a rope. It cannot solve all
your problems. We're talking about rope.
We're talking about tendon. So we had
the thought that okay, what if we didn't
stop at the rope? What if we said that
okay, if it works well for a tendon, if
it works well for the single dimensional
structure, what if we could move one
step forward and think about the
connective tissue of the human body?
What if we could create something which
we call 3D tissue braiding that is
capable of combining this technology
with the topological freedom that we
have in 3D space and create connective
tissue various design what we have laced
through our human [snorts] body. And
basically what this means is that we
combine the technology then the elements
that you saw on roiding and create well
sort of a matrix of a freely
programmable system that is capable of
creating these structures which amounts
to this. So basically what we have with
hologic is a robotics production
platform where this is the case of a
humanoid finger. The bones are pushed
through the machine and all the
connective tissues are woven around it.
In this case, what this means is that
this is the bones, four bones for a
finger, right? And it's really just four
bones. So there is not a single pin or
bearing or whatever else screw inside.
It's just the four bones. And the system
that is holding it together is the weave
itself, is the braid itself, is the
connective tissue itself, including the
tendons, including ligaments and
everything that is required basically
for its movement. And the whole point
behind this is that you have something
that is a single step instead of all the
complexity of your manual assembly
process for a very complex uh uh uh
mechanical system in a sense. And of
course I'm showing a finger here but it
could be whatever that's kind of the
entire point and you have this unique
ability to scale without limitations
because if I want to modify the tenor
routing the joint joint construction or
whatever it's just a matter of coding it
it's just a matter of designing it in
software and it's an automated step of
production and the result is a robust
compliant and body because
because it's it's composed of the
textile system and its inherent
properties which I'll soon get into but
the the the base underlying Princ
principle how this works is that you
have a rope raider essentially a rope
making system which is combined with
other rope breaking system braiding
systems and that you can freely
interlace and you see here maybe the
simplest unit which is simply a split
and that is what we're capable of doing
it multiffold and in various patterns
and whatever basically you can imagine
following the rules of ro breeding which
are pretty expensive you have a
softwarebased system where you can
translate your highle design a little
bit like slicing and 3D printing from
this high level design concept
mechanical engineering concept to actual
production code based on a topological
system. This is the algorithm behind it.
What makes it work? You don't want to
deal delve with the individual strands.
And the key benefits are is that you are
actually unlocking all the benefits of
biomechanics which means primarily for
this real and murky word impact
resistance because you have these f
instead of single weak points that your
pins are tiny tiny components represent
you have fibers hundreds of them
distributing load over a relatively huge
surface area ratio. So that means it's
much harder to break. If it breaks you
can you can just like a dislocated joint
you can you can put it back. You have
inherent a softness of course. So this
entire thing is based on textiles and
you have virtually unlimited complexity
because you can just design whatever you
want. You can and it's an added point
that if it's a fiber like it's
fiberbased technology if it's a fiber we
can actually work with it. So that means
that you can functionalize your tissues
with various types of materials, with
various technical fibers, various active
fibers, sensory fibers, whatever you can
imagine basically. And that is not
limited by the manufacturing platform
that is not requiring you to include an
additional step or sub assembly or
subsystem in your supply chain that is
just there. And of course the main point
to drive home is that it's fully
automated.
From the point that you have dreamt up
the design to the point that you
actually wire up your actuators, there
is absolutely no assembly required. You
just kind of cut it off the machine and
that's that's the manual step for now.
So what we are doing is to try to
transform this huge supply chain that
you have there which all of these
components and all of these players and
all of these necessities that will take
you hundreds of parts an insane amount
of time and effort and money to produce
a very complex robotic system and just
basically cut the middle of it out. You
still [laughter] need a few parts. You
still needed to work with it a little.
But the whole point is that you have a
single platform to eliminate most of it.
And just to show an example
uh this is one uh uh secondary product
that we did for customer already. So
it's we are an early stage company. So
this is not like it's it's out there in
scales. Yeah. This is a newly introduced
technology. It's a simple terror
operation use case. We did it actually
for electronics manufacturing where they
wanted to handle similar sight objects
and cables and optical connectors etc.
And what we have here is something that
is a three-finger gripper of a
semi-humanoid configuration, but it
could be whatever else depending on the
design needs and the customer needs is a
very easy matter of reconfiguration.
Just demonstrating a simple set of
tasks. And of course based on this after
this, it depends completely on the
actuator stack or whatever you want to
put behind it. If if it comes to that
different types of applications require
different types of full stacks, but the
mechanics and the key properties of them
can stay the same.
So what this amounts to ultimately is
that we live in a world where the
intelligence is becoming accessible.
More and more products and solutions are
out there for solving how robots learn,
how robots operate. We have amazing
initiative like like like hugging face
with the robot platform etc. which is
making it possible for anyone to create
the the system behind how robots move.
But what if we could do the same thing
with hardware? Imagine the possibilities
that could unlock. How you how you are
allowed to start thinking a little bit
differently about what hardware actually
does. How hardware suddenly is not
something which is like you know this
this little treasure that you have that
is so very expensive. It breaks all the
time. You have to take very good care of
it or you have to calculate with
replacing it all the time. But you can
create any sort of customization or any
sort of replaceable solution without
significant effort
for cheap. That's the whole point. And
you can still leverage all of the
complexity and all of the physical
advantages of something that we have
here in our human body and that we've
been trying so hard with conventional
engineering methods to replicate all the
time and we have it. And what an
additional benefit to the biomechanical
part is that since we work with fibers
that means that we have access to a vast
range of materials for very demanding
environments. Think about chemical
resistance, think about radiation
resistance. So simply the way of
thinking about it because of the reduced
complexity and because of the
functionality that's not impact impacted
is is broaden to an to an incredible
scale. We are at the beginning of this
journey but are super excited to see
what this will bring. And that kind of
brings us to the point of uh thanking
our beautiful team. It should be already
23 people up there but we have didn't
have time to make the new pictures but
we are expanding. So, if you're
interested in that, especially if you're
a mechanical engineer interested in
peculiar machines, here's the QR code
for you, hopefully visible. [laughter]
And with that, thank you so much for
your attention and visit us both outside
if you're interested in more.